Learner A4: معروف
Learner A4: الو.
Learner A6: شكرا.
Learner A4: أيوا صح؟ مير عوض.
Learner A6: بخير؟ الحمد لله.
Learner A4: وإحنا منتظرين عيار دراجة.
Learner A6: أنا مش عارف فين البيت بصراحة.
Learner A4: ، مصطفى انت معانا ولا.
Learner A3: داوود.
Learner A4: طيب أنا كنت بعتلك رسالة مبارح على شركة معرفش شفتها ولا لأ.
Learner A3: شفتها يا عمر ورديت عليك تقريبا.
Learner A4: لا ما اقولك طب يعني فهمت اللي بعتهولك ولا.
Learner A3: تمام ما هو ده اللي كان في خيالي عموما وبعدين رديت عليك ثاني يوم لشو.
Learner A4: صراع ممكن بتبعتلي مبارح فكنت بتكلم معايا لحتة الإيبو أين
Learner A4: أم
Learner A4: حقولك عايز بتقولي إيه.
Learner A3: تمام ماشي أنا فعلا ما ردتش وانا اصلا تقريبا رديت على حد تاني او حاجة لان في ناس كتير بتبعتلي عساكر
Learner A3: ما زال فاكر يرد عليك والله.
Learner A3: بقولك صح؟ ما ردتش بس أنا فعلا كنت فاكر أرد عليك لأن في ناس كتير بتبعتي.
Learner A4: مش عايزك إنك شفت رسالة.
Learner A3: لا شفتها قالتها تمام.
Learner A4: ماشي
Learner A4: كان مشهور بتاعك أصلا مش محتاج
Learner A4: أحمد علي جامد فرنش
Learner A4: الأوضاع مش هيفا
Learner A4: هو انتو امبارح دخلتوا عليه تاني ده.
Learner A3: لا، هو ما بعتش.
Learner A4: أنا فضلت مستني أي حاجة.
Learner A3: وأنا كمان برضو.
Learner A4: قالت لي لا الميتين كان موجود بس ما حدش دخل فين انبعت على طيب.
Learner A6: هو كان في ميتين امبارح كده ميتين جيجا.
Learner A4: هو كده كده إحنا عندنا ستاندرد عادي بس واحنا قلنا نفتح بالليل.
Learner A4: ما فيش حاجة ما عجبناش حاجة يعني
Learner A4: هي قالت لي على إمم مصطفى مصر بتقولي حبعتهالك ما بعرف انزين
Learner A4: بينزون أم
Learner A4: يوسف انت سامعيني صح.
Learner A3: أيوا تمام ما تقلقش.
Learner A4: رشا أيوا بعتت الكلام دا العطش.
Learner A3: تمام حراسة يعني.
Learner A4: السلام عليكم
Learner A4: ميرسي.
Learner A4: غيرها.
Learner A4: الحمد لله رجالة.
Learner A4: ايوا معاك معاك.
Learner A4: انت قد الدنيا. والله بس أنا عايز بيت.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A3: بالكامل يا ام عمر.
Learner A4: بجد.
Learner A4: سارة سارة مش سامعنا إحنا ردينا عليك والله.
Learner A4: ايوه انت رديت فين مهدي فين اسامة.
Learner A4: طبعا.
Learner A4: هذا والله.
Learner A2: إمم.
Learner A4: طيب.
Learner A6: شكرا.
Learner A4: يا رب.
Learner A3: انا بس كنت أروح حاجة عمرها.
Learner A4: حلو ماشي طيب قبل ما قول أديس اللي عندي انتو الدني.
Learner A4: بصرف بتكلمني مبارح فقالتلي على جنب كده.
Learner A4: حلو.
Learner A4: فقعد معه الان.
Learner A4: هو عامة. أنا يعتبر حليت لك الحوار ده
Learner A4: هو أنا معلش والله بس أنا قعدت العت في الفايلات بتاعتكوا كلكم.
Learner A3: يا عمي؟ همتها.
Learner A4: غير.
Learner A3: حللنا مشكلة اف بي اي.
Learner A4: بص هو في في اف بي اي دلوقتي
Learner A4: وانا بدرس كدا مع انتي جرافيتي
Learner A4: قل على إي بي آي ثري بتاع جروب.
Learner A3: ما بدأت في بداية.
Learner A4: انت انت شايف المسج صح؟
Learner A4: فين.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A4: تشات لأ.
Learner A4: طبعتها دار لو سرق.
Learner A4: أو.
Learner A4: واردة.
Learner A4: أم ماشي هو عامة. أنا بدأت أشتغل بجروح وانت كمان.
Learner A4: معلش عشان في تين غروب.
Learner A4: ده.
Learner A4: ماشي خلاص ما هي كانت دفعت.
Learner A4: تمام ده شغال عليه. اشتغلت عليه مبارح
Learner A4: هو ثري كوتة هو يعمل كويس في باي فلاين
Learner A4: وكل حاجة فطبعا خلصت باكند يعني متقفل
Learner A4: وأسامة برضو عمل بروجكت حلوة امبارح وشفته
Learner A4: الفكرة الوحيدة بس اللي هو عايز اوريكو أعمل سير ثواني
Learner A4: دي الصورة اللي بتطلع والمفروض احنا غيرنا وانا غيرت يعني في الفايل الايميج
Learner A4: بتطلع كده هو قال لي فين ده هيا، شكرا.
Learner A4: وده يعني ده بيطلع الصورة دي أنا مش عارف دي فهي تقريبا كرومتين إنجينيرينج هتزبطه
Learner A4: أحاول أتغير فيها يعني.
Learner A4: دوت إيراني.
Learner A4: تمام أوي وكدا كدا لو ديو بيطلع تمام ده شغال هنا في
Learner A4: ده ال إي بي آي وعملت.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A4: عملت علشان تستور الأستس والسادة.
Learner A3: عظيم يا عمر.
Learner A4: والأدلس.
Learner A4: تضغط.
Learner A4: كان.
Learner A4: كلها مبارح بالليل.
Learner A4: لا.
Learner A3: كلمنا معاه في الحاجات دي.
Learner A4: إحنا ك يعني علشان بصراحة أنا عايز الحوار يخلص عشان أنا.
Learner A4: إحنا مطلوب نعمل دلوقتي.
Learner A4: المطلوب. دلوقتي ماشي ب بالنسبة لك انت عمر بتشتغل على الشعور بتاع ستور ده
Learner A4: يعني حاولت شوف توصل يعني يطلع حاجة أحسن من كدا.
Learner A3: هو رأيي اصلا.
Learner A4: لا.
Learner A3: ومجموعة حاجات طلعت كلها فوق بعض او حاجة.
Learner A4: ما هو صدقني بص أنا دخلت على
Learner A4: وشفت اي حاجة ويعني مثلا كده فتحت مع السلامة.
Learner A3: ماشي ما يقدرش وكويس بس ليه كلهم كانوا لازقين في بعض يعني.
Learner A4: لوغو، ويمبل ده غرام.
Learner A4: إلى لم إن معرفش إيمتى اندب راوندينج باي تو مخاطر.
Learner A3: من.
Learner A4: المفروض الكلام ده.
Learner A3: تمام.
Learner A4: تمام تمام.
Learner A3: شغال.
Learner A4: شغالة هي الفكرة بس إن الكوتا بتفيط مني
Learner A4: دي بس هي المشكلة الوحيدة بس هي كفايت لاين لا شغالة يعني.
Learner A3: في الفيديو.
Learner A4: لا.
Learner A3: طبعا.
Learner A4: الفيديو بقى اللي أنا وصلتله يعني مبارح اللي هو خلاص يعني أنا فكني من طالما هو شغال ومشكلة كوتة بس
Learner A4: فحبدأ من ليفوكس حاليا مع مع اسامة في حوار
Learner A4: نشتغل على ألريدي وصل لحتة حلوة؟
Learner A6: الفيديو يعتبر عموما إن شاء الله يعتبر خلصان أنا يعني هوالك ومعاك حتستخدم وبس.
Learner A4: عيسى.
Learner A6: زبطة في بتاعك لأن أنا عندي برضه نفس الكلام أنا لعبت بكل الفيلات
Learner A6: فأنا كده حعدل تاني حاخد بس تيمبلتس
Learner A6: يعني اللي بيتعمل عندي وبس هم دول اللي احنا محتاجينهم طالما الباقي كله منضبط عندك ايا تقولي يعني.
Learner A3: عظيم.
Learner A4: تمام هو بس محتاج نقعد نشوف انت يعني وصلت للريفلتي دي ازاي الاول
Learner A4: قبل ما حد فينا أنا ألريدي شغال على برنش هنا.
Learner A4: تمام اللي هو كوبايليت ريفيو رشن
Learner A4: فهعمل عليه. كوميت وقبل لما أنا مرجع لمين محتاج انا وانت يعني نقعد لو انت تمام معاك اللي احنا نكمل الميكينج ده نقعد حبة فيه
Learner A4: يبقى احسن وحده لأن احنا كل مرة بنحاول نخشينج بعدين كل 1 فينا يعني.
Learner A6: إحنا ممكن فعلا دلوقتي لأننا فعلا فاصل ومش قادر
Learner A6: ما عنديش مشكلة.
Learner A4: تمام يعني نكمل دلوقتي عادي ولا قصدك بعدين عايز.
Learner A6: كله تماما لو الباقي كله الأول تمام كل حاجة أوكي ماشي
Learner A6: واحنا كلنا حنعملو حنشوف بس الفيضانات اللي أنا عدلت عليها. واللي. انت عدلت عليه وتزبط الدنيا و
Learner A6: وبس يعني تقريبا ان شاء الله يعني.
Mentor A: هل هو يا شباب سوريا؟ قاطعكوا عاملين
Learner A4: الحمد لله بخير يا حبيبي.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A3: كلو تمام.
Mentor A: حلو جدا جدا بجد فيري إمبريت
Mentor A: عندي بس يعني كوت إنسايت كده عشانهالكوا بالمرة عشان بكرا راتبه بقى نشوف الدنيا مشيت إزاي أوكي
Mentor A: على الفيديو عمر بعثهولي.
Learner A4: هبعت اللي إنت بعتهولي يا فندم.
Learner A6: أوف تمام كويس.
Mentor A: إينسايد بس بسيطة. هو انتو عملتوا بالزبط ال إنترو حلوة جدا تحفة
Mentor A: مع الحاجات بتطلع مع الكلام مش مرة وحدة. وهكذا بس هو حاجة وحدة بس محتاجين تشتغلوا عليها هي مش ريتش خالص
Mentor A: يعني هو ده طالع ده طالع في شكل إن إنت حرفان بتقول معلومة وتمشي بتقولي.
Learner A3: محتاج يعني اف بي اي اقوى شوية احنا شغالين بحاجات ضعيفة شوية.
Learner A4: بالظبط. لأن مثلا الأوديو اصلا اللي بيطلع دقايق
Learner A4: حضرتك عايز أساسا الفيديو اقل قصدي اكتر من كده
Learner A4: عايزاه ماكسيموم اربع دقائق نحن نتكلم في أفيراج دقيقتين ونصف دقيقتين 3 دقائق كده يعني.
Mentor A: لي.
Learner A4: التوقيت.
Mentor A: طيب.
Learner A4: ده الماكس.
Mentor A: طيب فهماك ماشي ممكن مثلا ماشي لو إحنا نعتبر
Mentor A: تشرحلي يعني عايزين إحنا نشوف يعني لو هنعتبر آخر دقيقة تشرح بوينت واحدة بس يعني مثلا الفيديو أوكي دي حاجة عامة جدا دي حاجة عامة جدا جدا فإنت ممكن مثلا تقولي وات إز بيلدينج إيماج ودي بقى في دقيقة ما تدخليش في أي حاجة أنا بس عايزة أشوف
Mentor A: مش إن هو أشوف ال فيشواليس اللي حتطلع من حاجة دي تيلد فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: ما هي الفكرة أنا عندي بقى يعني عندي سؤال هل انتو عايزينه كبيت شغال ولا يبقى بشكل كبير
Learner A4: لأنه هو لو بيس شغال فحم تمام لو غيرتوا
Learner A4: ولو مثلا في أي مش بطلع الحاجة بالكواليتي العالية بس مجرد اللي انتو هتلعبوا في في
Learner A4: هو البيت بتاعنا تمام بس فولي فونكشنال عشان نقدر نتس كواليتي
Learner A4: بالشكل اللي حضرتك طالباه أو الشركة طالباه كده هنبقى محتاجين أقوى
Learner A4: لأن زي ما تشوفي إحنا يعني.
Mentor A: ماشي جربت تشوف هوغنج فيس.
Learner A4: هوجن كيس. أنا كنت لسه بحاول أشوفه بس دخلت مع جروب لأن جروب كان أسهل يعني.
Mentor A: طب.
Learner A4: وهو.
Mentor A: بي اي مش أحسن حاجة ولا أنت مشكلتك في بي آي صوت ولا
Learner A4: ما هو هو جروب مثلا هو المكسمان بتاعته مية الف ممكن الخمسمائة 1,000 بس انت شوفي عندك كم
Learner A4: إحنا عندنا كذا إيجن واللي.
Learner A3: يعني كل 1 تقريبا عنده تو بي ريفيو على إي جنتو.
Learner A4: يا ما ما.
Mentor A: طيب ما ينفعش تخلي مثلا أسامة يطلع من الأكاونت بتاعه وال إي بي آي دي تتحط مثلا في ال سيمكلنر بس
Mentor A: ما يستخدمهاش أي حاجة تانية ومثلا بي آي تانية تتحط في أجنت كل 1 يطلع بي آي من عنده
Mentor A: بي اي دي اعمل اعمل كذا وكل 1 مناسب اي بي اي معين مش كلو.
Learner A4: عامة. فكرة كويسة يعني كنت أفكر.
Learner A3: هو هو عموما عادي بس هو احنا برضو لسا كدا يعني واقفين في نفس الحتة بتاعت إن ال بي اي ممكن ما يبقاش اقوى حاجة يعني برضه احنا برضه شغالين لسه ما غيرناش حاجة كده فبالتالي يعني ده يحل مشكلة التركنز.
Mentor A: بتخلص.
Learner A3: ده مش سيحل مشكلة.
Learner A4: كواليتي.
Mentor A: ماشي أنا عارفة إن إنت عشان تيست وتزبط كواليتي محتاج كتيرة وده هيستنزف الكوتا. أنا فاهمة بس أنا يعني بعتهولي ده هو نفس اللي إنت وريتهوني في في
Mentor A: الفكرة بس إنه تغير فيه ال إنترو ومتغير فيه إيه إن إنت ما تطلعش الحاجة مرة واحدة بس حتة دي هي لسا ما هي هو نفس الكلام حرفيا اللي أنا شفته مش أي حاجة غيرت
Mentor A: فلو إنت لو حتشرح لو هتستيك على دقيقة. خلاص أنا مش حطلع أكتر من دقيقة عشان حتة ال
Mentor A: اسمه اي ده الكوته ماشي دقيقة دي بس وانت تيست
Mentor A: على حاجة أعرف أشوف فيها. زي ما قلت لك ما تقوليش وات إز دوكر وات إز دوكر ده حاجة دي عشان ممكن
Mentor A: لو هتشرح فإحنا مش عايزين كده خد لي بس حتة من.
Learner A3: ممكن نغير التوبليك مثلا نتكلم على حاجة زي.
Mentor A: بالظبط.
Learner A3: حاجة بسيطة.
Mentor A: لأ ما حاجة كبيرة جدا تقول إيه مثلا لير في فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: ما شاء الله.
Mentor A: تبقى كافية. إن إنت تطلع مثلا شكل دوكر فايل أو تشرحه قالت لي ده حتة صغيرة جدا من كبير جدا
Mentor A: فممكن يبقى كوفيد في دقيقة، لكن آي والحاجات دي
Mentor A: عمرك ما حتقدر توريني عايز أشوفه في الدقيقة فاهمين قصدي.
Mentor A: فبس ثاني حاجة برضه حتة يعني حاسة إن ديه ممكن أطلع فيها مالطبين سينز أكثر من من اللي كان طالع في الباكر اللي إنت وريتهولي
Mentor A: عشان ممكن نزود السين دي ممكن تحطها جورد ريلز في تقوله حاول مثلا تطلع
Mentor A: مثلا مينيمم حطله مثلا مينيمم منيمبر يعني مثلا أنا مش عارفة أذاكر ده أنا شفت فيه كم سين
Mentor A: بس هي ممكن تحطله يشوف مثلا هو فداكر يطلعلك مثلا يطلعلك سفن سينس يقول له لأ أنا عايز المينمان بتاعتي يكون مثلا تناشط
Mentor A: ما تطلعش اقل من كده هل قصدك.
Mentor A: فدي تاني حاجة
Mentor A: فأنتو بالنسبة مجرد حوار إن إنت تحط لكل إيجنت إل ام مختلف من كل 1 أكاونت ليه
Mentor A: ممكن يزبط الدنيا شوية تاني حاجة
Mentor A: حاول تشوف لو بي آي إنتو شفتوا حوار إن إنتو تعملوا بايد جيمناين
Mentor A: في جروب عمله يمكن في جروب تاني عمله أنا شايفة في أكاونت جبنا واي.
Learner A4: أندريه.
Mentor A: إنت ممكن بس تبص على البرايس عشان أعتقد مش محتاجينه خلاص يعني خلاص قفلوه مثلا من فضلك.
Mentor A: فتشك إن هو ولا بتدفع لشهر ولا بتبقى ماشية إزاي.
Learner A4: فرنش.
Mentor A: خلاص لو في ممكن
Mentor A: تعملوه يعني ديفايت عليكوا شوفوا يعني شوفوا يعني إنتو حيبقى الدنيا عاملة إزاي لو لقيتوه بيسحب قوي يعني مثلا جربوا يعني حطوا حطوا كريديت أو حاجة وجربوه
Mentor A: يومين كده لو لقيتو إن هو بيسحب أوفر بس آي دونك بيسحب أوفر سحب أوفر خلاص ممكن نستغني عنه بس ما أعتقدش إن هو على السكوب ده نوع حيسحب أوفر يعني
Mentor A: بس منطقي شوية في تيم ثاني ألريدي عملوا عمل الموضوع ده فقلت أقول لكوا يعني لو.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي ماشي هنشوف الحوار ده.
Mentor A: وبرضه يعني آي كونتراستيج أكثر مثلا تو بوينت فايف برو مثلا في حاجة كودينغ الكلام ده معرفش بروكس.
Learner A4: هو تمام ماشي هو الفكرة اللي هو أغلب مش أو اللي إحنا شغالين بيه مش كود يعني مثلا كود
Learner A4: وبيتم او بالتاكس بس.
Mentor A: مش مش عارفة الصراحة ممكن إزاي بالزبط يعني هل هو بيكفي حاجات بتكتب ولا يعني ممكن نشوف بكرة
Mentor A: بس هم دول شوفوا بس أحوجي من الأول
Mentor A: عشان يسهل عليكو يعني يسهل عليكو أصلا بسرعة إنتو عمليا على طول بتستوا كده مش متحكمين بالكوتا والكلام ده
Mentor A: فحتى ممكن بس يومين لحد ال تيستينج لما يخلص تأكدوا إن في حاجة مثلا بتطلع خلاص شيلوه وخلوا واحدة بس للآخر دم ولا حاجة واعملوا سيف للحاجات الكويسة اللي طلعت الفيديو الكويسة اللي طلعت اعملوها سيف حطوها في حتة.
Learner A4: هو احمد منصور قال لي انا اشاهد.
Mentor A: في قلك إيه.
Learner A4: كده إحنا شفنا حاجة ثانية دور على إميدريشن.
Mentor A: لا، لا، طبعا لا طبعا مش الكلام ده لا لا
Mentor A: ممكن يكون رد غلط ولا حاجة
Mentor A: ما في أكيد مش حروح عشان حاجة بي أو سي يعني أكيد ما حدش يعمل كده
Mentor A: لا لا هو هو إحنا شغالين سامعيني ولا شو بيقطع.
Mentor A: أكيد يعني مش حروح كان قصده دور على زي لاما والحاجات دي
Mentor A: وكوين والحاجات دي إنت بتنزل يعني بتنزله تران لوكال على اللابتوب بتاعك مش وفي نموذج ثانية فيس
Mentor A: بس يعني عايزين ننجز فمثلا مش حأقدر أجري ورا حاجة بطلع كواليتي وحشة وأقول طيب أدخل في اللب دي فاهمين.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: إن شاء الله إمم فبس يعني فال كومنت بتاع وأنا كده كده لحد بكرة يعني قفيله بالنهار ده لحد
Mentor A: ماشي ممكن.
Learner A4: أن.
Mentor A: كنت.
Learner A4: إيه ماشي.
Learner A4: ماشي يا فندم في حاجة ثانية.
Mentor A: لا هو بس دي أهم حاجة بلاش بقى زي ما قلت والكلام ده حتة صغيرة جدا زيشرح كوفر دريتش أكثر من إن هو ينشرح في حتة واحدة
Mentor A: الأول قبل ما تبتدئوا تغيروا في ال.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: أوكي ثانك يو يا شباب ربنا معاكم.
Learner A4: شكرا.
Learner A4: عمر.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Learner A3: طيب تكملوا، كنتوا تعملوا.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A4: أنا.
Learner A3: اللي كنتوا تعملوا.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A4: ليش.
Learner A4: هي كانت تتكلم بسرعه فانا لم افهم ما سمعتهاش اصلا.
Learner A4: لكن.
Learner A4: موضوع أحمد.
Learner A4: هي بتقولك لا ما ما فيش الكلام دا
Learner A4: لأن أوبن سورس يعني مش حيطلع كواليس هيزع حاجة كواليتي عليه متطلع كل.
Learner A3: طب إحنا عايزين تدفعوا.
Learner A4: يعني ولا
Learner A4: والكريم أحمد منصور.
Learner A4: يعني المشكلة ان هي قالت خالص ماشي.
Learner A4: حصل في حصل دلوقتي حوار الكلام معاكو.
Learner A4: صح ولا بيضة صح يا حوار يعني.
Learner A3: انت رأيك يا عمر.
Learner A4: أنا تمام.
Learner A3: هاي وانا حاسس اننا لم يكن من المفروض ندفع في الانترنشال انتخابات.
Learner A4: لا، هو أنا كده مع الحوار.
Learner A3: هم كده قدموا لنا انت فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: هو هو يعني.
Learner A3: لك.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A3: هو مش ناخذها لما نعجبهم في الآخر أصلا.
Learner A4: لا ما أكيد بتنحي.
Learner A4: هو متهيألي بص هو أظن موضوع انترنت انك تتعامل مع ناس عامة أكثر ما هو بيقولك تعمل فاهم.
Learner A3: طب ما أي حد في الكلية يعني كيف يعمل كده.
Learner A4: لأ ما إنت في كل إنت إنت شغال انت وجمايلك اللي في جروب محدش بيمينتر عليك فاهم.
Learner A3: ماشي يعني دعينا نخرج من هذه الحاضره هذه بي اي.
Learner A4: و أنا مش عايز بس لو ما اعرفش يعني هو.
Learner A3: جيده ام لا.
Learner A4: هو مش بروك أساسا اللي مطلع البتاع ده يعني هي الصورة مثلا دي مش اللي هو بولونيشن ده
Learner A4: بتديلو كرامته على حسب الكرم ال فويس بناء على الكريبت اللي طالع طالع من جروب من جروب من جروب.
Learner A3: من.
Learner A4: لا.
Learner A3: إحنا عندنا أصلا كذا موديل يعني كده انت عندك كذا بي اي مش مش.
Learner A4: لا بالزبط.
Learner A3: طيب بص
Learner A3: إحنا خلينا على موضوع كواليتي ده عشان انا احس الموضوع ك بي أو سي كواليتي ممكن تبقى منطقية مش لازم تبقى عظيمة جدا. ممكن تبقى منطقية وأنا حاسس حتى الآن أنا ما شفتش ارتوت
Learner A3: شايفة السينز وشايفة الكلام مطروح كويس وبتقول لك هو الموضوع كبير مش مش فولي كوفر مش هيبقى فوليكوفر بدقيقة ممكن انقي الموضوع صغير
Learner A3: ونشوف هنقدر نعملها ازاي
Learner A3: بالفري كوتة التي نحن نعمل عليها لحد الآن.
Learner A4: بالفريكوتا مش عارف فأنا شايف مش حطلع كواليتي اللي إحنا عايزاه أو اللي هم عايز.
Learner A3: أم.
Learner A4: عارف شهادة طب بيشارك معانا يعني.
Learner A6: يعني بصراحة بص أنا كنت شايف إن هو يعني ازاي مصطفى بيقول إحنا في الموضوع.
Learner A4: 5.
Learner A6: دي نقطة ومش كدا بس بنطلع الكوتة إحنا نتكلم على حوار انه
Learner A6: والحاجات اللي بتطلع مش حتبقى أحسن حاجة زي ما هم بقولولك فأنت ما تجيش يعني ما يجوش بعد كده يحاسبونا على إنه الحاجة ما طلعتش كويسة. بسبب إنه إنت الكوتا بس يعني مش فكرة الكوتا الفكرة نفسها. إن الموديل نفسه هو مش قوي كفاية. يعني أنا عندي بستخدم.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A6: بالظبط كده يعني أنا بستخدم ده أساسا يعني هو طبيعي موديل ضعيف جدا
Learner A6: مقارنة مثلا لما تستخدم حاجات تانية كتير جدا حتبقى أقوى منه بكتير في
Learner A6: فده اللي أساسا كان عامل معايا مشكلة في إنه بيطلع معايا الفيجوالز مش أحسن حاجة الأنيوشنز كانت كتير مشكلة لغاية لما ظبطت فيعني هي دي المشكلة الأساسية أساسا.
Learner A4: أعتقد أن الموضوع.
Learner A2: أعمل يكون سالم وخلاص.
Learner A3: بالطبع.
Learner A2: هم يغيروا اي بقى يبقى يطلعلهم نتائج حلوة.
Learner A3: يعني.
Learner A2: أن.
Learner A3: تكون أجزاءها شغالة بشكل حتى لو يعني سيفنتي بيرسنت شغالة يعني كواليتي سيفنت بيرسنت ده كويس جدا جدا واحنا شغالين.
Learner A2: هو مش.
Learner A4: عامة.
Learner A2: ممكن يغير عادي ممكن نستخدم إيه قوي ليميت بتاعه مثلا قليل نحنا نطلع فيديو 1 بس الحاجة بتاعتنا شغالة كويسة وبعدين نغيره اللي احنا شغالين عليها عشان.
Learner A4: ما هو ده اللي أنا كنت لسه قوله كومنت بس هي أو
Learner A4: هي زي الفل شغالة تماما حتى كل اللي طلعت هنا ممكن اوريكو الشات وهتلاقي حرفيا كله شغال في الكوتا
Learner A4: كله شغال في الكوتا وحتى كمان أنا مش شايل بتاع اللايت إيلين
Learner A4: بالعكس أنا سايبه يعني لو جينا هنا شوف انت عارف.
Learner A3: الحاجات دي صح؟ ولا رأيك.
Learner A4: أنا عايز أعمل ميرج للكلام.
Learner A3: زي الفل عشان نخش لو حد مثلا يعدل في حاجة بالضبط.
Learner A4: عن.
Learner A3: إمم.
Learner A4: يعني انا شايفة ومخليه فيرست أوبشن لما هو يجي يعني.
Learner A3: صح كده.
Learner A4: ، عامل فول باك لو هو ما ينفعش هنا بينزل تحت على
Learner A4: بكل حاجه يعني حاطط هناوي راوتر.
Learner A3: إمم.
Learner A4: ألريدي هم.
Learner A3: ممكن نعمل لينك سوري؟ انا ممكن اعمل اي بي اي لكل 1 فينا زي ما قالت بحيث يخلص بسرعة دي حاجه.
Learner A4: حلو.
Learner A3: دي كانت فكرة لطيفة و
Learner A3: ونشوف يعني أوتبوت هيبقى عامل ازاي عشان هي برضه ليها كذا تعليق على ال سينز ومش عارف السينز تتغير ليه.
Learner A4: ما هو اللي أنا كنت عايز أقوله لمحمد مهدي سرقني إحنا ممكن نجرب نعمل فيد بي آي
Learner A4: منه بس فيديو 1
Learner A4: منه فيديو 1 بحيث إن هو يبقى اللي هو بروف زي ما بيقول يعني هو شغلنا تمام.
Learner A3: ما فيش مشكلة.
Learner A4: معمول لها كل الكلام ده شغال.
Learner A4: ده اللي في دماغي بس إيه رأي البنات.
Learner A3: لا ده بالنسبة لي فكره كويسة جدا احنا طول ما احنا بنجرب عادي احنا بنجرب راحتنا وعلى حس ان التجارب بتاعتنا كويسة نيجي نطلع فاينل اولدود كويس وده البروف
Learner A3: نحن ليس لازم نتكلف كثيرا من أجل عملية ديفلوبمنت خصوصا الحمد لله يعتبر مخلصين يعني.
Learner A4: أوه، ذي هاي.
Learner A3: بس عشان نسلمهم حاجه نضيفه ممكن ندفع. نعم، انا ما عنديش مشكله سندفع في التسليم يعني
Learner A3: هذا الذي هو تثبيت الشغل كما يقولون.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A3: يعني في مرحلة وبعدين يحصل مشاكل يعني مثلا حد يسحب أكتر من التاني في عملية ديفيلوبمينت دي محتاجة يعني عملية تنظيمية معقدة شوية.
Learner A4: لا، لا، هو أنا بالنسبة لي.
Learner A3: تمام يعني.
Learner A4: لا، انا ما كانش عندي مشكلة في اللي أنا كنت موافق عليه في اللي هو زي ما قلنا في مرحلة بس يعني مش مش اللي انا حاخد ال بي آي دا.
Learner A3: هذه.
Learner A4: وبتشتغل عليه.
Learner A3: إنمنجت.
Learner A4: بعد هتسحب كتير فاشلة.
Learner A3: بتسحب أكثر مني، فأنت تدفع اكثر مني يعني عارف الحاجات دي.
Learner A4: بالظبط بالظبط.
Learner A3: معالجتها. تبقى جدا.
Learner A4: بالزبط. لا لا
Learner A3: ميشيل.
Learner A4: طيب.
Learner A3: تيكست مثل.
Learner A4: بالزبط.
Learner A3: فنحن نعمل نقسم ال تيست علينا دي بسيطه.
Learner A4: تمام هو ال تيست أنا ممكن حتى 1 بس هو اللي يقوم بيه لو انتم تمام
Learner A4: او لا يعني خلينا ماشي كلنا
Learner A4: خلينا كلنا بحيث ان هو كل 1 يتكفل أول.
Learner A3: على غد او على الحد يعني لو نقدر نعمله غدا لو استطعنا ان يكون لحد عملنا فاينلايز للديفلت
Learner A3: طيب قولي رأيك.
Learner A4: هو أنا شايف. إن إحنا ممكن ننجزها النهارده يعني.
Learner A3: طيب طيب.
Learner A4: بيني وبينك بصراحة، أنا الأسبوع اللي جاي أنا في مصر وحبقى مسافر أصلا
Learner A4: فشغال من الخارج هاخد معاه اللابتوب وهسافر
Learner A4: اريد ان اخلص كل المشاكل الكبيرة او قبل ما انا اجي ابقى برا.
Learner A3: ما فيش مشكلة أنا قاعد معاكم.
Learner A4: إيه مضبوط.
Learner A3: يعني أنا كده كنت عايز اخش معاك انت واسامة وأنتم شغالين في تقدر تبدأ.
Learner A4: طيب طيب اسامة
Learner A4: أسامة سنيوري.
Learner A6: لما وزعنا معاك.
Learner A4: هي تباني ولا.
Learner A4: إمتى نقدر نخش نربط الدنيا دي.
Learner A6: بشرب.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A6: ما فيش أي مشكلة.
Learner A4: طيب يلا بينا.
Learner A6: بالعكس. أنا بقولك أنا شوية عموما وقدني انفصلت أساسا
Learner A6: ومعرفش امتى وممكن اتصنع وسام وفي أي وقت لو عايز دلوقتي انا معاك.
Learner A4: طب يلا ينفع تعملي بس شيرش كريم.
Learner A6: أوكي أكيد ديه بالزبط.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: طب ممكن بس ولا أنا مطلوب مني حاجة تعملها ولا يعني حرجع.
Learner A4: إحنا المفروض اللي إحنا اتفقنا دلوقتي هنحاول يعني نجيب ونبقى نشتغل ببسا
Learner A4: حيبقى مش هنشتغل بيه دايما احنا عايزين بس نطلع فيديو 1
Learner A4: عايزين نطلع فيديو 1 فنحن عايزين نتأكد الأول من كواليتي بتاعت كل حاجة عندنا
Learner A4: وبرضه قبلها طبعا لازم نخلص الجزئية بتاعت علشان تنتج مع ال الباكند.
Learner A4: ماشي بس جمرايا عادي ولا أنا فهمت وانا فهمت.
Learner A4: هو هو عادي ما هو في الأغلبية.
Learner A4: فرنش.
Learner A4: ما هو حيبقى في جيمي لان انت عندك.
Learner A4: مش حتحمل كل 1.
Learner A4: طب هي عشان بس في حتة ولو كل 1 فينا من الحتة الاف بي اي.
Learner A4: الموضوع. ولا ننسى لا علينا حتة هي.
Learner A4: عن.
Learner A4: فكرة حلوة. أنت قلت ساعتها هي فكرة كويسة.
Learner A4: ما هو الحقيقة هي مش كواليتي وايد أحسن حاجة يعني
Learner A4: يعني انت في في الصور. هل انت طلبت صور كويسة
Learner A4: حاجات كويسة.
Learner A4: لا ما أقدرش أنا ما فيش قدامي غير يعني كلامه نعم.
Learner A4: بالزبط. ما هو المفروض اللي انت طلعته.
Learner A4: هو بيقفلوها يعني هو الكل بيطلع الريش مثلا مش حلو اوش مش مشركوكشن يعني.
Learner A3: لا عمر إنت بتطلعي.
Learner A4: أنا أتكلم.
Learner A3: الله يبارك.
Learner A4: تكلمنا.
Learner A3: على يعني انت بالجنرال.
Learner A4: رحمة الله.
Learner A3: يمكن كورس الجوفة.
Learner A4: مش بتكلم عن الحتة دي بتكلم لما تجارني أسيت بورت لاين بيقولي بيجبلك السكريبت.
Learner A4: ماشي مع.
Learner A4: أنا والدتك أنا والدتك امبارح هو ده اللي بيطلعلك.
Learner A4: والمصطفى.
Learner A4: وريت ال مصطفى ولا لمين.
Learner A4: ولا.
Learner A3: الخرطوم.
Learner A4: وروتك عامة.
Learner A3: كان بعته في في.
Learner A4: ، ماشي هو كان تيكست انا ظبطت المفروض خليني الحاجات اللي عندي عايز بس اتأكد منها. الأول ثانيا.
Learner A6: أنا أشيل آيس كريم دلوقتي عندي.
Learner A4: ماشي سيس كريم.
Learner A6: أوكي إن شاء الله
Learner A6: المسكين كلها ولا الباب بس بالنتر سكايب.
Learner A4: هي هي ندى مش ما بقتش معانا ولا عشان هي مش شايفة داخلة معانا في.
Learner A6: إيه.
Learner A4: عملت بروجرام.
Learner A4: طب هو مين ماسك كومبوزيشن دلوقتي.
Learner A4: ما فيش.
Learner A6: ما فيش فلوس عشان كده حاولنا بيشكو.
Learner A4: التمرين.
Learner A6: وعمان ال كان آخر فوائد. انا بعته
Learner A6: هو ده المفروض اللي بيطلع دلوقتي عندنا.
Learner A4: انت عامل شيس كريم خلاص ماشي.
Learner A4: طيب ده بيطلع بناء على.
Learner A6: يعني.
Learner A4: يعني إيه الكود اللي بيطلع الكلام ده.
Learner A6: ماشي بس.
Learner A4: فهمت قصدك.
Learner A6: هنا ماشي إحنا معانا أساسا يعني أول حاجة خالص اللي إحنا نستخدمها لي فيها فين والكلام ده كله
Learner A6: فدي دي حتبقى موجودة في الكل أي لغو جديد هيطلع
Learner A6: وبعد كده جوا بقى في النص كداوت التغييرات والكلام ده وللآخر
Learner A6: نفس الكلام مش حيبقى عامل ازاي هيبقى كدا سريعة وبس وخلصت على كده.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي انت الكلام اللي بيطلع ده بناء عليه يعني.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: الكلام نفسه بقى من السين اللي هيبقى مصطفى
Learner A6: ففيين هنا أنا هنا برضه أنا كنت عامل أسيت كده عشان بس شوية خالص بس هو بيعرف إحنا شغالين على إيه وأنا عليه يجبلي دوت عشان أستخدمه
Learner A6: المفروض بقى بيستعملوا هو تيم للثواني هو ده ولا الثاني القومية تنبتر أو الرز
Learner A6: ماشي ال ريندر نفسه ده بياخد بقى الجسر الفايل ده وينعمله ده إيه
Learner A6: يحولوا يعني الفايلات اللي احنا عايزاها.
Learner A4: ماشي يعني عامل إزاي.
Learner A6: اللي أنا بحتاجه بكون الجسم بايل ده بالزبط هو بمواخد ده اللي هو.
Learner A3: بتاعي صح.
Learner A6: بالزبط ده كل اللي أنا محتاجه حرفيا إنت بتديني ده وخلاص
Learner A6: وبناء عليه، بس بقى هي الفكرة كلها إننا بعتمد على أسيست. اللي أنا بطلعها مش العمر بيطلعها
Learner A6: هيبقى كل اللي محتاجه إنه بتاع ده
Learner A6: إنه حعدل برضه عندي إنه جروح للأسف يعني جيبها من هناك مش هيبقى موجودة ديسكريبشن الحاجة برضه ولا الأسد بتبقى الصورة من غير أي وصف ولا حاجة.
Learner A4: بيبقى لينك بيبقى لينك للسود.
Learner A6: إمم طب أقصده لينك نفسه اللينك نفسه دوت حيكون في أي.
Learner A4: يعني مثلا حبعتلك دلوقتي إكزامبل.
Learner A6: ماشي هي بتبقى كذا صورة صح ولا هي صورة وحدة بس وكده.
Learner A4: كذا صورة.
Learner A6: طب ماشي حلوة طب بس ده كده ممكن يكون زي بالزبط الشغال عندي.
Learner A4: افتح الشمس.
Learner A6: شكرا هو افتح الزي.
Learner A4: انت عامل كذا سكرين صح.
Learner A6: ، لا أنا من.
Learner A4: يضغط.
Learner A6: كلكم.
Learner A4: يضغط على لزوم.
Learner A6: سويناها مش عارف.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A6: ماشي طيب ثيس
Learner A6: ماشي أنا معرفش بصراحة هو ده هيبقى تمام ولاء لأنه هو الفكرة إنه عندي عشان هو بيكون بالفعل عارف الأسد ده أساسا تبع فبناء عليه بيعملوا
Learner A6: فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: تاني كده.
Learner A6: يعني أنا عندي نفس الكلام. أنا مش قريت صور أو هيكونز بنفس الطريقة. دي.
Learner A4: يعني الطريقة اللي انت وريتهالي يعني.
Learner A6: اللي أنا بعتهالك ال يو أر يو. أر وبناء عليه، يو أر ده هو ده اللي بستخدمه.
Learner A6: بس ولكل سين ده هو بيبقى عامل أسيتس ياخد ال يو أرز دي بس أنا.
Learner A4: بالله.
Learner A6: الكريبشن دوة هيمشي ازاي بصراحة بالزبط.
Learner A4: يا سيدي. انت ماشي معاك تمام.
Learner A6: ال سكريبت هو اللي أنا بستخدمه حاليا كان شي ايس كريم ماشي
Learner A6: اللي أنا بستخدمه حاليا أساسا هو الجسم ده اللي أنا برضه
Learner A6: فهو ده ما فيهوش أي حاجة من الكلام
Learner A6: أنا لما جربت أشتغل من بويب لاين نفسه بصيب لاين الله عليه فين فين داتا هيدي داتا ايوا تمام
Learner A6: ده برضه عشان للبتاع بس مش.
Learner A6: بفتكر ليه لأن أنت في الأوركسترا.
Learner A3: الوضع في مشكله في. لكن اعتقد ان انت هكذا لو انت شغالين وتطلع ده كويس جدا.
Learner A6: ما هو أنا لو معاه دلوقتي الأسد ده كان طلع تمام خلاص هو يحط الأسد هنا.
Learner A3: طب في حاجة بعد.
Learner A4: كلام يعني.
Learner A3: يعني.
Learner A4: خش كده عالفايت لاين معليش بعتذر يا مصطفى.
Learner A3: لا، لا، مهنتك.
Learner A4: الكلام حيخش عالفايت.
Learner A6: شايل دلوقتي ده أسد اللي انت خدته أو.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Learner A6: ماشي.
Learner A4: حلو.
Learner A6: دلوقتي مصطفى حط هنا.
Learner A4: انت اصلا انت لسا هناك؟ هو أنا عملت عملت إيديت أنا عملت إيديت للكلام ده.
Learner A6: ما هو أنا عشان أخدت البرنش قبل ما تبش.
Learner A6: بس فعشان كده بقولك إننا محتاج حاليا. إني أديك ال فويلز بتاعتي كومبشنز عشان ما تبص يعني.
Learner A4: يا جماعة.
Learner A6: يعني الفكرة.
Learner A4: أستاذ.
Learner A6: سألت سؤال عشان هو تقريبا كان مخليني أعدل جزئية هنا فيجوال كيس خلاها بالشكل ده تقريبا وخلاني أضيف في إسمها إيه
Learner A6: لأ يبقى مش هندي.
Learner A4: أب أسامة
Learner A4: حقولك على حاجة انت كده كده عشان تبدأ اللي انت تبوش على برانشيت لازم تنزل كوميتش اللي قبلها
Learner A4: دلوقتي. أنا ال.
Learner A6: ماشي.
Learner A4: اعمل كده وقف.
Learner A4: أنا طلبت من أنتيك دافيدي اللي هو يتشكل
Learner A4: بروجكت كله بيقولي إيه المشاكل اللي فيه لأن هي لو كانت كوتة بس أنا كنت حبص
Learner A4: هو دلوقتي قالي فيو معرفش إيه عندنا أول حاجة كريتيكال يوز إنفلات تين تايب سندلك فراش تمام معرفش
Learner A4: مصطفى ده الجزء بتاعك صح.
Learner A3: دي
Learner A4: تمام بص أنت شايف.
Learner A3: أه.
Learner A4: اللي.
Learner A3: إنجيلش سكيما أونلي لوس ماسينج مضادات ليست ويل كراش ويث فاليديتور أير تو الفكسروكتور سينج بيو أر ماشي.
Learner A4: تمام والباجة الثانية تو ناروا ده بتاع مين في برضه ما اعرفش ما اعرفش إيه تمام
Learner A4: عندي هنا مشكلة في الأوركستر.
Learner A3: طب انت ممكن تبعتلي بقى عمر الحاجات دي عشان الحاجات دي أشتغل عليا دلوقتي.
Learner A4: ما هو أنا عايز نخلصها دلوقتي علشان أخش علشان اسامة يبدأ يعمل مظبوط عشان يعرف. هل في مشكلة في
Learner A4: الباك اند واللحمة تمام.
Learner A3: ما فيش مشكلة هو حتى الآن قريته كان حاجه ناقصه في البيدينتك فده عادي يعني
Learner A3: فده ان شاء الله نقدر نعمله دلوقتي.
Learner A4: ماشي انت عندك كده مشكلتين في مشكلة في الأوركستر معايا السي بي اس تقريبا معاك صح معاك.
Learner A3: مصطفى.
Learner A6: اتي اس.
Learner A3: هذا.
Learner A6: بيطلع من نفسه على طول.
Learner A4: السي دي اس كوبايدر.
Learner A6: هو.
Learner A4: ده انت اللي عامله صح.
Learner A6: لا سي آنية.
Learner A4: بصي اللي أنا عامل عليها.
Learner A6: من
Learner A6: دي اس بروفايدر ده موجود فين بالزبط أني فايف.
Learner A4: في بروفيدر.
Learner A4: انها حتلاقيه.
Learner A6: هو عموما المفروض الاجر من نفسه هو اللي بيعمل باس كيب بتاعتي مش مستخدم بروفيدر كامل كتير.
Learner A4: طيب طيب.
Learner A6: عشان كده كنت بقولك إحنا قبل كده القديمة أنا
Learner A6: يعني هو اختصرهم في الإتي تيميل بأنه هو حيطلعلك ال سكريبت كده اللي حيطلع من الصين لأنه هو في الصين بيبقى واخد التكست اللي غير في الصين نفسها،
Learner A6: فهو حيقرأ حيقرأ التكسي ده بس كده يعني.
Learner A4: طيب ماشي هو احنا ممكن نعمل حاجة
Learner A4: انا ممكن هبش في الكلام ده
Learner A4: تمام هتخوص كل اللي أنا عملتو.
Learner A3: دلال.
Learner A4: ونقدر نطلع بعض.
Learner A3: عندنا غير نموذج يعني إنت غيرت حاجة عندنا غير ال اف بي آي كيس أو ليش.
Learner A4: أو.
Learner A3: تمام.
Learner A4: أنا أنا غيرت في يعني هو أنا ما وسعتش حاجات كتير ده العدد يعني
Learner A4: انا ممكن ابعتهولك نص كود ده.
Learner A3: لا ماخدش ده ما هو مش حيبان حيبان أعتقد لما تعمل. كوميديا.
Learner A4: انت هتعرف تشوفه يعني.
Learner A3: ما هو بيبان من على.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي أنا غيرت في الدايريكتر غيرت في ال غيرت من بإيه بالظبط.
Learner A3: آخر.
Learner A4: بس أنا مش.
Learner A3: ممكن.
Learner A4: والحاجات. دي يعني ما تحتش حاجات.
Learner A3: طيب تمام خلاص.
Learner A4: زودت.
Learner A3: عشان ترام كويس عادي ما فيش مشكلة.
Learner A4: زودت حاجات بسر معايا.
Learner A3: أزودلك الفيلد اللي هو عايزه اللي بيعمل ان شاء الله.
Learner A4: ال إيماجيز برضه يا عمر معلش يعني قعدنا نلعب.
Learner A4: قولي.
Learner A4: الجوية.
Learner A4: تونس.
Learner A4: زودت لو.
Learner A4: ؟ والتشهير.
Learner A4: نفس الكلام دي تيست العاديه علشان تقاس الكلام دا المتر ده صح؟
Learner A3: بس.
Learner A4: قضائي.
Learner A3: وكل ده مش هيعمل مشاكل او كل ده مش هيبقى بالنسبالنا اللي انت زودته كله عباره عن حرفيا التوصيله بحيث انت تركب في هذا بالنسبه لي تمام.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: إنت.
Learner A3: موضوع.
Learner A4: أوه.
Learner A4: لو ينفع تبعتلي كده مثلا يعني لو عندك
Learner A4: تسألوا مثلا هو إيه عمل إيه في عشان أنا برضه شغال عليه دلوقتي. ويبقى ما يكنش شغلنا.
Learner A4: أنا حاليا ممكن ممكن هقوله بروسي يعمل للكلام. دا تمام.
Learner A3: طب ما حلو ده.
Learner A4: يعني الكوطة فيها قد أنا خلصت 50 في المية من المفروض بقى.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A4: إمم
Learner A4: طيب ماشي خليني أغير الموديل
Learner A4: حيغير الكلام ده هعملوا كوميتر اسامة انت معايا صح.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A3: يعني هو حرفيا حرفيا زود 5 سطور و سطرين عندنا.
Learner A4: ده ما هو.
Learner A3: ده.
Learner A4: في ده. ما انا بقولك هو قبلها كان مزود كوتيك.
Learner A3: طيب ماشي انا اجلس للحاجات لو في حاجة مش فاهمها بس عادي أهم شيء الدنيا تشتغل.
Learner A4: هي الدنيا شغالة. تمام ما غيرتش في يعني مثلا.
Learner A3: من.
Learner A4: الأولى.
Learner A3: أنت عملت.
Learner A4: صورة.
Learner A3: الباي لاين عادي.
Learner A4: ده بالضبط يعني اللي أنا لعبت فيه كله
Learner A4: وال تيست برضو علشان تعدي من الجسد ويبقى الدنيا تمام.
Learner A4: وانا اعلنت.
Learner A4: تسألني يعني
Learner A4: يكتبلك مسج كده لو عندنا عشان هبعتهالو عشان هو دلوقتي بيلعب في ال عشان ما يغيرش اللي انت عامله أو يعمل حاجة.
Learner A4: مستوى.
Learner A4: ساعات عندك عمل حاجة ممكن يلغي اللي انت عملته أصلا.
Learner A4: أنا عارف أنا بخلص هنا وأولا ما أنا أجي أعمل
Learner A4: تمام
Learner A4: كويس. يا حبيبي كويتي يا برضو يلا يا بابا
Learner A4: كل الأوران دي ده بسيست مع أهله ماشي طيب
Learner A4: طيب أسامة أنا المفروض أخلص الكلام دة دلوقتي وهعمله بوش وانت خدوا عندك.
Learner A6: توب تمام.
Learner A4: بدي أشتغل عليه.
Learner A6: خلص أوك ماشي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: هو أنا بس أنا أنا لو آخده عندي إزاي آخده عالبرنش. نفسه ولا ما ينفعش.
Learner A4: تقدر تاخده على البرنش عندك.
Learner A4: بيتهيألي تعمل ورش.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: لا انت ممكن في كل العادي من البرنش بتاعي برضه.
Learner A6: طيب ماشي بشوفلك.
Learner A4: دلوقتي حتى كل حاجة
Learner A4: ماشي
Learner A4: وليه طيب.
Learner A3: انت كدا بترول بايد لاين كلها.
Learner A6: أنت عملت بوش عندك دلوقتي.
Learner A4: لا، لا.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A4: انا بتسأل أول. هل حيعدي تمام ولا لا مفروض كلو تمام لحد دلوقتي
Learner A4: فرنس
Learner A4: أم
Learner A4: إمم
Learner A4: ولا الكوتا كده
Learner A4: مردود
Learner A4: هو يا شباب ممكن لو حد عايز يطلع تمام وانا حخلص وهعرف.
Learner A3: طب عمر انت ممكن تدخل معانا تاني بالليل.
Learner A4: أنا تمام،
Learner A6: بص أنا برضو عموما أنا فهمت دلوقتي عموما الدنيا ماشية إزاي كل اللي حعملو إننا هاخد الفونشن اللي أنا حطيته في الأوركسترا عندك
Learner A6: وأحطها تاني في الفوائد اللي أنا ممكن أعمل حاجة عموما عشان الحوار دوة ما يعملش يعني هو إني آخذ كل حاجة
Learner A6: يعني حصلح بس الحاجات عشان مش عايز بصراحة الملفات نفسها تضيع ولا
Learner A4: ما هو بص انت اشتغل على برنش تاني.
Learner A6: إمم.
Learner A4: يعني انت اللي معاك ده انت شغال على براند صح.
Learner A6: أه.
Learner A4: اعملوا اعمل سويتش على برانش تاني
Learner A4: و وأعمل كل على الحاجات الجديدة.
Learner A4: الحاجات دي حتيجي على برنش فإنت ما اشتغلتش يعني الشغل بتاعك هو نفسه بس اللي انت كنت عامله كدا كدا لسه موجود فاهم مزبوط.
Learner A6: يعني قصدي أسيب البرنج بتاعي أعمل برنش جديد من مين.
Learner A6: طب ماشي حلو.
Learner A4: جديد من من الحاجات اللي إنت ألريدي كنت عاملها فاهم.
Learner A6: اللي أنا عاملها بالفعل.
Learner A4: ، فاهم وتاخد الكلام اللي أنا عملته في البرنش بتاعي اللي هو دا.
Learner A6: اها.
Learner A4: وتبدأ اللي معاك معاك نفس معك نفس الحاجة
Learner A4: نفس الفايل اللي انت عملت لها ايدك اللي انت عملته؟ تمام.
Learner A6: ماشاء الله.
Learner A4: وفي نفس الوقت برضو انت اخدت الحاجات الجديدة والقديم لسا انت مرضتلوش.
Learner A6: طب حلو ممكن أعمل. كيف حالك.
Learner A4: فاهم قصدي.
Learner A6: خالص بسيطة بإذن الله.
Learner A4: إن شاء الله يا رب.
Learner A6: أنا هدفع دلوقتي و.
Learner A4: ماشي أنت تعرف تدخل بليل.
Learner A6: الساعة كام مثلا.
Learner A4: انت تسحبها كام.
Learner A6: ما أنا ما أعرفش المشكلة؟ أنا معرفش دلوقتي أنا هنام لو نمت دلوقتي أصحاب والله
Learner A6: لأن أنا من الصبح برا ويا دوبك رجعت على ميتينغ فأنا عشان كده مش عارف والله الأسبوع دوت نومي فويس خالص.
Learner A4: عامة. أنا تمام معاك يعني ممكن من الساعة تنين وحدة.
Learner A6: أجرمان.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A6: يعني أي وقت لتوصلوا له إبعتو على طول وأنا لو شهيد هشوفه على طول يعني وتمام لو عرفنا نخش كمان معرفتش بس يعني إن شاء الله أهم حاجة أخلص الدنيا يعني أول ما تعملوا على طول.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: ما شاء الله ما تسمعني.
Learner A4: ماشي ماشي هوة كريم فلانينغ المفروض.
Learner A6: والله.
Learner A4: أنا كده ممكن.
Learner A6: وريني كدا وريني كدا أوي البطولات كم سين طلع.
Learner A4: إيه.
Learner A6: أو.
Learner A4: عندك.
Learner A6: كم 1.
Learner A4: آلية.
Learner A6: ضمن ضمن الاسم نفسه.
Learner A6: 3 و4 إمم.
Learner A4: وال بويس أو.
Learner A6: إمم.
Learner A4: خلاص يعني برضه مش حياخد وقت
Learner A4: حش على الاسف هو المفروض خلاص تمام يعني.
Learner A6: ، جايك
Learner A6: خالص بإذن الله بسيطة للرجالة نخلعها دلوقتي.
Learner A6: إن شاء الله.
Learner A3: عايز اعرف لنا اسمه يعني كويك أبديت كده.
Learner A4: اللي ناقصنا اعملوا اشتغلوا على اللي أنا حبعته دلوقتي ده وخلاص هو تمام.
Learner A3: وين.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A3: المفروض. انا اعمل.
Learner A4: خذوا عندك بعد ما تاخده عندك شوف الدنيا الحاجات اللي عدلتها دي تمام مش تمام حاولت رن عندك شوف هيشتغل معاك ازاي
Learner A4: انت بردو بقى عندك اكست على
Learner A4: بيسمع ولا لأ بيسمع كويس بيسمع وهيسمعرفش
Learner A4: من الآخر و واشتغل على بتاعتك حاول تحسن كواليتي بتاعتها كواليتي كواليتي
Learner A4: بس لحد ما نشوفها هنشتري ال إي بي آي ولا هنعمل إيه.
Learner A3: وصلت.
Learner A4: احنا اتفقنا إن إحنا هنشتريه بس نتأكد إن الباك إند تمام متربط تمام بحيث إن هو ما يسحبش كتير.
Learner A3: ماشي هو كده ناقص ناقص شغل اسامه انه المعمول دلوقتي صح كده.
Learner A4: والآسف معهم.
Learner A3: تمام إحنا بقى نخش بالليل تاني.
Learner A4: أنا تمام.
Learner A3: قلت اتنين وحدة
Learner A3: بس خلينا نخش بقى عشان يعني نخلص الأسبوع فخلينا نخش بحيث ان انت لو محتاج تعديل من أي حد أو محتاج تعديل في أي حاجة نبقى احنا
Learner A3: مظبطين الدنيا مع بعض انت فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: أنا فاهمك ده اللي فعليا عايز أوصله يعني.
Learner A3: انا ما عنديش مشكلة يعني شوفوا ان شاء الله تخشوا امتى وانا معاكم ان شاء الله ما عنديش اي مشكله يعني ابعد في اي.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A3: أبعتلك على إمتى يعني هتنام.
Learner A4: أنا في الأغلب لا مش نايم يعني في الأغلب بخلص البتاع ده
Learner A4: وأنزل يعني أعمل كوميت و أنزل.
Learner A3: طيب وانت اشوف كده عندي الدنيا ماشية ازاي اشوف التغييرات اللي انت عملتها بتسمع ازاي انت فاهم قصدي.
Learner A3: لحد ما تاتي في الليل بحيث لو عندي تعديله اعرف اشتغل عليها.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A3: خلاص تمام.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A3: زين كل عمر.
Learner A4: معلش اخر سؤال.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: التوعية صح.
Learner A4: طيب أنا مطلوب مني
Learner A4: خلصوك.
Learner A4: طلعتوا.
Learner A4: بس ماشي.
Learner A4: ا خلصوا.
Learner A4: طب أنا المفروض. أربط حاجة من الكود.
Learner A4: لأنا هعمله كوميت دلوقتي خش على البرانش بتاعي وانا حبعتلكوا يعني كومبغداديشن
Learner A4: إزاي تعملو فول عندك على البرنش بتاعك و وده اللي انت تركتو.
Learner A4: كل من فرنسا وامسح.
Learner A4: ما انت خشوا بقى اعملوا عندك وكده انت لما انت بترن هنا؟ اصلا
Learner A4: هو بيدلك كل حاجة يعني هو انا مثلا دي صورة
Learner A4: بعد ما انت عملت رون حتدا تمام لا بيس
Learner A4: مع السلامة وتبدا تشوف كواليتي بتاعتك فاهم ويبدأ بقى خود مثلا
Learner A4: خود له جزء من اللي كانت موجودة في الفيديو ألريدي
Learner A4: خلي اسامة يبعتلك اللي هو الشغل اللي هو كان عمله واللي عايز زي دي
Learner A4: خذ مثلا ال تيم بتاعت فرنس نفسه ولا عايز حاجات تبقى ملائمة مع الويب الكلام ده كله
Learner A4: وطبعا لو لقيت طريقة تانية احسن من كدا اللي انت تجننيت بيها احسن واحسن.
Learner A4: ما أنا بحاول ابعتلي.
Learner A4: بقول.
Learner A4: بعث لي دلوقتي أنا هطلت المسجست عشان برضه تبقى 7 انجليزي
Learner A4: هو عايز مني عايز أشوف كونفيرشن ديسك فرنش
Learner A4: شغال على الإستميل تو إم تي فور كونفيرجن تيست بورت لاين عايز يفهم كوليكشن سيج عشان ابوت يعني
Learner A4: عشان يكسر فلو شغال تمام.
Learner A4: أو.
Learner A4: هو عايز سامبل.
Learner A4: مش محتاج الكلام ده زي ما قلت.
Learner A4: هو مش محتاج إن هو الكلام ده ألريدي يعني احنا لو وصلنا مزبوطة ومش محتاج اللي هو
Learner A4: يعمل الحساب دي لأن هي ألريدي هتبقى فيلت إن يعني.
Learner A4: بيقول لي كدا معرفش دخل 200 جنيه كمان.
Learner A4: مارس.
Learner A4: ثواني خش ألو سلالات.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: يخص.
Learner A4: إمتى.
Learner A4: انت حتقف دلوقتي.
Learner A4: المفروضة.
Learner A4: طيب،
Learner A4: النهاردة.
Learner A4: أنا تمام والله يعني.
Learner A4: امبارح سارة مبارح سارة. قلت لها كانت بتسألني واحنا في ميتينج قلت لها حنعمل ميتينغ تاني
Learner A4: بعد كده سألتني بعدين قلت لها. ما تعملش قالتلي لا كان في ميتينغ ما حدش خدها
Learner A4: كنت عايز أقول إمتى الكلام دا حدا.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A3: يا عمر معلش هو انت هتعمل ميرجع الكلام ده على المين ولا انا اخدو من برانج بتاعك هعمل بول من برانج.
Learner A4: حتخدم.
Learner A3: طيب ولا انت تبعت لنا كونفيجريشنز.
Learner A4: هبعت لكم.
Learner A3: على سيركل في.
Learner A3: طيب زي الفل ماشي انا اخرج هكذا وسنتظر ان شاء الله وساعود على طول بول واشتغل
Learner A3: انظر هكذا الدنيا مثل الفل.
Learner A4: حبيبي.
Learner A4: لا مشرف.
Learner A4: سوري.
Learner A4: ماشي باي وا.
Learner A4: مغتص يوسف لسه بقى.
Learner A4: أول في شو دخل دلوقتي.
Learner A7: أنا أخرت ولا إيه اللي حصل بقى.
Learner A4: أنت إحنا كنا.
Learner A7: تصدر.
Learner A4: صباح الخير يا نور.
Learner A4: والله.
Learner A7: يعني بصراحة كان عندي ظروف بس اللي حصل.
Learner A4: بص هو يعني اللي أنا فاهمه ان انت مش محتاج اللي انت بعته ياه.
Learner A7: أوكي ماشي تمام.
Learner A4: يعني عمر برضه.
Learner A4: الو الو سامعني.
Learner A7: يا.
Learner A4: أيوة سامع سامعينك.
Learner A4: طيب ماشي انت الجزئيه بتاعتك.
Learner A7: بصي الجزئية. بتاعتي والله دلوقتي اللي هي كانت
Learner A7: اللي هي الحتة بتاع ام بي فور
Learner A7: الجزئية بتاعتي كانت قالت قبل كده الفرح او كده كانت تتأكد حتتة الباكند ولا تفوت بلغني بيها عشان لو كدا تغيرت بتاعي يعني فمعرفتش تعمله في البروجكت ولا لأ.
Learner A4: هو تمام هو تمام طلعنا فيديو مظبوط في سهلة يعني هي.
Learner A7: نوف.
Learner A4: يعني مش محتاجة اللي هي تبقى.
Learner A7: أم صامت من.
Learner A4: اقول لها الكلام ده.
Learner A7: ماشي خلاص زي الفل غافل.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A7: آخر.
Learner A4: انا اتوكل على ضيفك.
Learner A7: كلنا ماشي أهلا وسهلا.
Learner A4: بوي.
Learner A4: باهي.